at a cemetery northeast of gaza city two
hamas policemen
killed in tuesday night's attacks were
brought for burial
in all three policemen were killed in
two separate blasts
hamas's gaza police chief was here to
mourn his men
and promise a strong reaction
we have made arrests and we are
investigating people to ensure we get to
anyone who could be responsible for the
attacks
but things are under control and the
security status is good
daily life is back to normal gaza's
interior ministry says two suicide
bombers carried out the coordinated
attacks
on two checkpoints two policemen were
killed and a bystander injured in the
first explosion
the third policeman died in the second
blast minutes later
by day police were back on duty where
their colleagues had died
reinforcements stationed on streets
throughout the city hamas
announcing a general alert for all the
instability and violence the people of
gaza have had to get used to in recent
years
these attacks have still sent a ripple
of shock around the territory
targeting the very institution that is
supposed to provide internal security
and right here in the heart of gaza city
the attacks are widely believed here to
be the work of salafi groups
with links to isil in 2016 hamas agreed
to help
egypt in its fight against isil fighters
in the sinai peninsula
restricting their movement across the
egypt gaza border
i believe that as we see further
security coordination and cooperation
between hamas security services and
egyptian security approaches it seems to
me that we see
further tension between hamas and isil
further bloodshed between hamas and isil
as we saw saw it last night and i don't
think this is going to be the last
incident
this month has already seen increased
instability with rockets fired into
israel
attempts by armed men to breach the
border fence israeli airstrikes and
artillery fire
targeting gaza now a source of internal
instability has been made fatally clear
hamas is insisting it will maintain
security
and punish those behind the attacks
harry fawcett
al jazeera gaza